quella a tutti i ragazzi e prevenute
questo video sono vari j
e oggi ragazzi siamo il nuovo horror con
loculo street non vedeva l'ora di
provarli questo ve lo posso garantire
giuro prima che cada qualcos'altro a
soffitto direi che possiamo cominciare
quindi le scarpe o makino trovarsi una
porta davanti che non c'entra una mazza
è sempre la cosa più bella della storia
c'è qualcuno in casa sono fuori j mi
sono perso sono in mutande a bresse dei
pantaloni da prestarmi vi ringrazio e
una sedia c'è una una stanza con una
sedia perfetto c'è qualcuno che ha
voglia di di spiegarmi cosa dovrei fare
qua parte guardare la porta c'è una
parte molto bella che cazzo me frase di
canto una canzoncina mi aprì per favore
una roba a casa la parola chiave è la
parola magica è harry potter si è aperto
un cazzo vulnus in fabula
apriti porta del cazzo se la parola
fosse minchia quadrata cosa
mischia quadrata picchia quadra tra la
parola ragazzo in minchia che se siete
in dubbio ragazzi minchia quadrata
funziona perché c'è una stanza tutta
nera che capita o salve ciao sono
famiglie cioè di pantaloni si lasciano
più meriti che siate ma quanto segnò
casa zia come stai questa qua e mia zia
ragazzi che rappresento io cosa giusta
ma fai uso di droghe zia zia c'è un uomo
brutto che ha sbattuto la porta è visto
di coach song and who schiaffino e anche
il mio culo esiste nei posti oscuri lo
sai a place piano fisico long standing
perché puzza di merda se non cercare un
automatico che figo sentiti anni a
[ __ ] volevo te io volo solo il tema
non soffri pensato io
bene io voglio il mio pene un buon mix
con glutine
ascoltami il problema
ciao frate chiara e se n'è andato ha
segnalato non voleva voleva il mio pene
lo so che voleva il me senti perché come
si sa i canucks st guareschi
ok ho in mente te io posso farlo va bene
ma raccontare baby di justin bieber se
ne vanno bene
beh no
la juve come ben si sa mai dove ben
kingsley gilberto ho capito non ho
capito un cazzo ragazzi però va bene lo
stesso non vedo niente bene
cmq no vabbè vabbè ragazzi no vi prego
ascoltate lenzuoli con le gambe
io sono famiglie sono tranquillo non mi
toccare ti prego sono vergine dal culo
ma ascoltare tienitelo in faccia quel
coso che è ovvio
oddio sono in mutande sono in mutande
sei una [ __ ] malaschini comunque
piacere fa vj non lo stavo scherzando
quella o mio dio removed in seta è
finito e così che bello minchia che il
gioco di merda la prossima volta
plaudiamo sulla faccia dei creatori di
questo gioco non perché proviamo non
altro visto che siamo così belli bello
cazzo minchione tette che gran voce
ragazzi ha però fatto che ho le tette
ragazzi c'è qualcosa di sembra il tipo
mirror's edge nella roma solo con la
crus rift una figata montati che morbido
sti gran cazzi va beh ti dovrebbe essere
tipo mirror's edge più o meno pro loco
swift mirò seggi ragazzi un gioco dove
bisogna saltare da un palazzo all'altro
quindi l'ho fatta se prova perché voi
che cosa non è sto gioco
adesso devo passati sotto in modo figo
ho dato una testata che sono morto ho
sbagliato scusate non evochiamo che
madonna che ansia su che cazzo fai no sì
certo ma mai credimi non sono vivo io
scendo così le scale di solito comunque
regala trovati questo gioco per chi non
lo sapesse me lo spiego io i temi nella
vostra vita quando avete visto una
camminata così sexy
intanto le tette ragazzi posso fare
quello che voglio ecco perfetto domanda
di qua ma non è che voi non potete
capire il senso di nausea che da sta
roba c'è veramente orribile ciao
devo saltare sul palazzo di sto cazzo
ecco cosa non si fa per andare a
prendere l'autobus ragazzi cazzo
no ok ma posso giocare sul tetto grazie
mamma molto gentile sto capendo di nuovi
sto andando perché ci sto andando e
compie pop e ci sto andando madonna lo
devi su francia vuoi fare zia perfetto
scavalchiamo scavalchiamo di tutto ci
provo ragazzi a camminare sul muro ma
non so non ho idea di cuba ma proviamoci
normale come primo tentativo
pensavo peggio sezione guardano da ma
perché ho fatto io ho fatto nuova beh
come mai nella vita proprio no vabbè
come ho fatto ragazzi dove obama con le
sue medaglie dove le voglio tutte ho
scoperto tra l'altro che si può fare
anche queste ragazze la roba per bene
che mi sta uccidendo però figo e vabbè
già vado stata quella che la 1000 mie
pope bilanciano male cioè non è che sia
così semplice
graham patia sta minkia cavalca si no si
ok ok perfetto
tu che tu e dalla fine sull cazzo guarda
strano ragazzi come giammai figgis ci
riproverà vita sta roba bellissimo il
nuovo bravissimo madonna mia madre
sarebbe fiero di me anche il mio
insegnante di ginnastica bravo bravo zio
l'autobus è sempre più vicino alla
fermata è prossima il cazzo stiamo
andando lega devo aggrapparmi al tubo
io mi attacco al tuo voto attaccati al
cat bravissimo bravissimo cioè
bravissima scusa
sono vivo stavo per morire in romania
che la kerr perfetti importante e va beh
minchia lo scivolo non andavo sullo
scivolo raga da quando ero bambino cioè
cinque minuti fattori assi muri di
dovrei passare correndoci sopra invece
salto malissimo prova beh chi se ne
frega
ok ok troppa roba troppa roba dove sono
le mie medaglie dove obama s'è risolto
c'è un medico e la madonna ci fa più a
dominare di me statista vado mi suicido
di suicidio
non ho mai capito dove dovrei andare
però va beh no no no scherzavo e vabbè
morto
se io scendo piano piano tipo così che
poi non si sa cosa come mai nella che
cazzo di polpastrelli charlie perché
cazzo sei spyder è sono dentro
l'edificio sono riuscito a trovare i bug
anche in un gioco però con lo slip
ragazzi dai ragazzi concluso fine
episodio anche perché mi sono perso però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io concludo
che un episodio io auguro a tutti quanti
un sorbetto al limone mentre a gli
haters una vada anche laura anche la
voce di facebook e con nemico tra tante
scrizione se avessi 33 ragazzi
[Musica]